toi la victoire me revient et c'est une
victoire de fonds
bâti sur des convictions depuis trois
ans je trace ma route à l écoute des
français avec mon projet avec mes
valeurs et progressivement j'ai senti
cette vague qui a brisé tous les
scénarios écrits d'avancé
ma démarche a été comprise la france ne
supporte pas son décrochage
la france veut la vérité et la france
veut des actes ce quinquennat
ce quinquennat qui s'achève a été
pathétique
il va falloir y mettre un terme et
repartir de l'avant comme nous ne
l'avons jamais fait depuis 30 ans
pour cela j'aurai besoin de tout le
monde et ce soir j'ai une pensée
particulière pour nicolas sarkozy
j'adresse alain juppé un message
d'amitié et d'estimé et de respect
alain alain est un homme d'état et il le
reste aucun candidat n'a démérité cette
primaire fut digne pas un électeur ne
doit se sentir humilié ou mis à l'écart
ce qui nous unit est tellement plus
important que ce qui nous distingue
voilà pourquoi ce soir je tends la main
à tous ceux qui veulent servir notre
pays
un succès mon succès je le mets en
partage
je le dois à mes équipes je le dois à
mes soutiens je le dois à tous les
bénévoles qui furent admirables de
dévouement
ce succès ce succès je le dois à ces
milliers de français que j'ai rencontré
et qui m'ont nourri de leur révolte de
leurs idées de leurs espoirs
je me suis senti porté par leur désir de
liberté et de réussite
il y a dans notre pays un immense besoin
de re a une force qui attend son heure
et cette force elle sera extraordinaire
si nous savons la guider vers des
changements inédit
chez elle de voir j'ai le devoir de
vaincre l'immobilisme et la démagogie
la gauche c'est l'échec l'extrême droite
c'est la faillite
je parle de vaincre ces partis
politiques
pas de vaincre ces français déçu ses
électeurs qui ne sont pas aujourd'hui
des nôtres mais qu'il me revient aussi
d'entraîner vers l'avenir
françois hollande a abaissé la fonction
présidentielle il faudra la restaurer si
le peuple français me fait confiance
j'aurai le devoir de respecter le
contrat nous et avec lui et de tenir ma
charge avec dignité
je mesure la gravité de la situation et
les attentes de nos compatriotes
je vais aller maintenant à leur
rencontre
je vais relever avec eux un défi aux
or le défi de la vérité est celui d'un
changement complet de logiciels
alors je donne ce soir rendez vous à
tous ceux qui savent que le bonheur est
une conquête
je donne rendez vous à tous ceux qui ont
dans le coeur la fierté d'être français
mon ambition c'est de hisser la nation
vers le meilleur d'elle-même et je vous
le certifie si en 2017 nous prenons
fermement les choses en main alors notre
pays ira loin
parce que rien n'arrête un peuple qui se
dressent pour son avenir
chers amis mes chers compatriotes avec
ces primaires c'est une espérance tiéné
et bien ma mission c'est de la faire
grandir pour la france et pour la
république